lo so che lo aspettavate da una vita lo
so che lo aspettavate non mi faccio
aspettare le quanto so sprofondando che
brutta cosa non la voglio vedere e
orribile è bruttissimo alla mia fobia
più grande è questa perché sono una
calamità per pesci o del mangime per
pesci addosso cosa è successo
ancora un po più sotto trova la città
perduta di atlantide zio
beh cosa come cosa cos'è caso ciò l'alga
branchia no non ho capito fermi non ho
capito vi giuro come faccia respirare su
cosa cazzo è successo sto respirando
sott'acqua bene cioè larga branchia come
harry potter o bene non informi seguono
i pesci seguitemi all'arrembaggio a
trovare one piece chi cazzo è strage
chissà subacquei morti
michele cassano nel mezzo dell'oceano
non ho capito come faccia respirare
sott'acqua mi sono salve vengo in pace
ma già adesso io respiro sott'acqua tu
no su camerati che mi ha passato sto
potere di respirare sott'acqua a tiziano
no perché a sto punto non avrebbe senso
che io sia morto tutte le altre volte
che cosa è successo ragazzi quello che
state vedendo e la mia fobia number one
se io fossi questo bambino in questo
momento morirei anche perché non saprei
respirare sott'acqua ma quello è un
dettaglio
[Musica]
e più grossa della vagina della mamma
degli haters i che è tanto più è così
c'è una pala delle gambe c'è un corpo
sgozzato grazie non ho fame bisogna fare
devo sorpassare la palla si beh risi o
cazzo
mi devo aggrappare ho capito aggrappati
vai perfetto ce l'ho fatta sembra una si
è aperto e uscito un cadavere non fa
niente quindi io posso salire
salgo ok tu che cazzo siamo cos'è un
sottomarino questo cos'è sta roba
quella un lavandino
quello è un topo ragazzi qualcosa così
psicosi che palle
pensavo di essermi ritorti di torno no
dopo una vita e mezza è tornato quello
che mi dà la scossa girare la roba no
perché non ce la faccio non faccio in
tempo
e vabbè come dovrei fare spiega mi di no
dimmelo veloce veloce oggi
ok funziona perfetto fa chi è già fatta
bene ce l'ho fatto che culo
e ora che cazzo ad usarlo come
piattaforma pure come se non bastasse se
va beh no perché mi ammazza prima forse
lo so come va dai [ __ ] bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye veloce veloce
l'osso perfetto minchia una vita ci ho
messo perfetto vai o non moriremo è
perfetto pietrangeli poi perché non
riuscivo a fare un saltino così mica che
problemi ok arriveremo prima o poi a una
fine ma non è questo il giorno devo
centrare il buco in questa cosa sono
esperto ce l'ho fatta mi piace l'ho
fatta sul serio
non pensavo mai sony move i miei amici
pesci ciao pesci ma forse avevo
semplicemente uscire a michiara più
semplice di quanto pensassi scusate
pesci amici miei tornerò più tardi si
sta roba
ma ciò che da vari cos'è sta roba
c'è una merda non l'avevi peso si è
chiuso ci sono riusciti a trovare
complimenti la prossima volta uso la
scala te lo prometto che non l'ho vista
allora se riuscisse o fantastico bene
quindi ora sì che la mia vita è completa
se o del tempismo cosa che io non ho
forse riesco non era proprio quello che
volevo fare però devo riuscire a
cliccare in modo tale da spingerlo tipo
porca [ __ ] non pensavo così tanto
scusate io non volevo giuro nella così
difficile che faccio e ho studiato
fisica due anni mica per niente che so
fare queste cose che amiamo finisce la
sua ho calcolato proprio
perpendicolarmente al ipotenusa se devo
portare da qualche parte non ho capito
dove ma ok ok perfetto lo tiro su e poi
chiudo a me raisi no ma dai ma che cazzo
minchia che tragedia ogni volta allora
ragazzi non ho capito cosa devo fare ma
va bene devo portare questo da qualche
parte non so dove ma ok non è che tipo
devo così ecco come sarà ok avrò
raggiungere l'acqua va beh a meno che
non gli atti voti di tutti e due
così era vero non è vero non è vero non
ci credo come d'altro che cazzo ci
perché sono so bene perché c'è l'acqua
sul soffitto do staccare le cose dal
pozzo sottomarino gigante
ma esce un boss gigante che ben muoio mi
dico e mi mangia vivo
e invece no dove entrare io sono tastino
posso chiedere perché c'è dell'acqua
sopra e l'aria è stato difficile
parecchio però sono usciti salve ragazzi
come state tutto ok come va andiamo
posso fare qualcosa per voi no prendo
questa cassa sori hi tech di scassa
estra in tour in fani welcome cazzo se
della gente qui che cosa mi piaci fall e
la gente qui fatto io mi sono nascosto
dietro la cassa alla solid snake cioè
non mi ha visto nessuno fantastico hamas
tardi che porti il figlio a vedere dove
lavori e perla dove lavora il papa
guarda che bel lavoro di merda che fa il
papa qualcuno mi spiega come falsaci
della gente qua bene
ok non ho capito perché di questa cosa
ma va bene credevo di essermi
allontanato nella maniera più
incredibile da quella fabbrica invece
nota anzi c'è ancora più gente
fantastico con contentissimo guarda ma
che quanto figo livello che qui due alla
finestra non si sono accorti che io sto
facendo ste cose le prove ok ragazzi in
teoria così dovrebbe andare in teoria è
poi non sono un mago delle teorie quindi
boh ok adesso no perfetto se rimane
convinto reato riuscire a passare vai
vai veloce spesso salta qua sopra
perfette bellissima sta roba che poi
manovrare l'acqua come vuoi e bellissimo
perfetto fa chi è bene ci sono delle boe
perché non dovunque vado ci sono delle
cose che sembrano delle bombe sempre
gente appesa tra l'altro per rendere la
cosa ancora più macabra lo anche lui
respira sott'acqua e non sia stavo
scherzando non avevo visto che c'era
limite dell'acqua non me n'ero accorto
via vai via meli e veloce veloce veloce
fa chi è fatto
la madonna
scusate non volevo giuro se vivi a sono
vivi fantastico mi seguì non seguite mi
mettete paura l'ansia che cazzo volete
non ho il casco come lei mi seguono
non è che mi uccidono nel dubbio io
scappo magari non mi uccidono e pro non
ne sono sicuro quindi scappo a
prescindere va bene jolo se mi uccidono
sono morto
grandi ragazzi reggo è che via libera ti
prego devo portare di nuovo tutto giu
vai tiro la leva tirare la leva quindi
adesso se mi spingono di sopra
io dovrei riuscire e spingete vi
spingete più forte mammolette fantastico
seguitemi lega o quarto bella questa
cosa quanto ci metto poco a farmi degli
amici adesso adesso cadeau e nel mentre
che cado schiaccia il pulsante poi
quelli mi prendono io ce la faccio
però devo fare proprio così perfetto mi
chiamo io stesi tutti fantastico vai
così ragazzi seguitemi c'è un bidello
ciao zio come stai anche lui uno zombie
sono tutti zombie sori aygun zombie e ne
cia in tour bifani ma all'estero
l'enfant richiude mi fate passa
dall'altra parte senza suicidarvi grazie
bilanciate forte thank you guys no come
ma no ma no non volevo siete scemi
va bene non fa niente perché c'è gente
che corre nella porta che è successo ma
spunta godzilla
io ce l'ho costo godzilla prima questo
un tra un titano niente raga io vorrei
tornare indietro si sono suicidati tutti
fantastico grazie ragazzi iolo
importante che come avete fatto a
sopravvivere
così è successo come no vabbè non è
possibile ma ci succede così sto gioco
che io non mi spiego va bene non fa
niente ok non ci facciamo troppe domande
perché c'è del sangue per terra non ci
facciamo troppe domande
se servito tutto sto tempo e che ho
fatto niente
mi avete fatto cagare in mano deficienti
banner avvisate prima meglio lanciando
un pulsante un plugin che avvisa non ho
niente boudou eroso i suicidano teste di
culo con ragazzi adesso che ciò sto
controllo wireless na figata e ve lo
dico ok non avevo capito sono stupido
nel caso non si fosse capito un cazzo
maestro posto vai vai vai vai sopra
sopra sopra velocissimo velocissimo fuck
yeah meraviglioso ragazzi miei
bellissimi stati meravigliosi grazie ad
esso fa vj deve andare a salvare il
mondo però grazie di aver fatto la
vostra parte bene che ma il piano 4 o in
teoria dovremmo essere
siro ed è ancora caldo sherlock colpisce
ancora ragazzi c'è una cornetta che
rimbalza ancora qualcuno è stato qui è
molto recentemente 6 voglia nel
frattempo mio ordini una pizza cosa sto
per vedere swan salve
tanti guarda nigella cosa più
raccapricciante che abbia mai visto non
vogliono anche avvicinarmi non voglio
sapere però vanno youtubers la
videocamera be a tutti ragazzi questo
nuovi doneda va sul vetro che questo
salve ma ad attento tete s'ammazza uno a
caso completo cosa state guardando ciao
fratello ma non mi cagate più posso
guardare anch'io senza che mi sto
private grazie brave ragazzi che
proviene episodio di inside il prossimo
episodio sarà l'ultimo non avete idea
non avete idea continua la frase perché
potrei spoilerare non con non dico
niente ma non avete idea o non vi
immaginereste mai che cazzo centro
quello va beh spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi 50.000 laiche esce la l'ultima
parte [ __ ] cosa mi è piaciuto
l'argomento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni minuto a
prendere description sensori si discute
di ci vediamo il prossimo vito dai
ragazzi